guys today i have a developer from
instagram here to talk to us and tell us
a little bit about the new instagram
video that we've all heard so much about
june thank you so much for being here
thanks for having me
so first can you introduce yourself to
us and tell us what you do at instagram
oh yes so my name is june you know i'm
one of the lead developers here on
instagram video and you guys may have
seen our work we he had over five
million video uploads in the first day
wow i mean that's kind of amazing
the thing that's crazy to me is how did
you guys come up with this idea i mean
it is such an innovative idea i know you
guys like to use that word a lot but how
did you come up with it we here at
instagram well actually facebook because
facebook purchased instagram because we
realized that no one was actually using
our service anymore to post photos
oh everyone was posting on instagram so
we just bought them we just we just
bought them
okay
so we came about this idea because we
decided that we wanted our photos to
move and moving photos equals video it's
quite simple really okay i guess it's
simple so what's the whole concept
behind filters i mean you guys have been
using this since the very beginning the
real reason behind instagram originally
is we realized that everyone thought
that they were a photographer but they
were not we they're basically just these
stupid peons posting photos on the
internet and they were absolutely just
horrific so we decided let's give these
perpetually
unintelligent peasants a way to share
their photos and make them look
professional
i'm sorry did you just call us all
peasants
yes uh i did actually
okay well
there's a lot of debate going on online
about vine versus instagram and that's
pretty much all everyone is talking
about since you guys released this new
feature i'm sorry i don't think i'm
familiar with this debate that's going
on what is the uh what is it called
again you've never heard of vine you can
share six second videos it's loopable
and shareable and it's kind of twitter's
answer to video i've honestly never even
heard of this service that you're
talking about but what's more important
we let you post videos that are longer
than six seconds and we do not believe
in loopable videos
okay so disgusting all right uh how long
have you been at instagram i've been at
instagram since day one i i think i've
actually started the application i made
it all i coded it myself and my free
time oh yeah it's been great it's been
uh it's amazing i can't wait to spend
some of this facebook money
go to the mall perhaps i'll buy a new
handbag
maybe get a haircut thinking about maybe
getting my eyebrows waxed what do you
think
do you like it
you could let them open or something
i mean like it's kind of a strong word
uh i mean maybe you could use a little
something
well anyway can you give us a demo of
the new instagram video oh yes oh let me
find my
phone of course i always use my phone
silly me i'll be right here so when you
find it let me know
did you find it yet
oh yes just just one second please i
found it never watched now it's not
going to be useful
cool easy actually you just hit the
photo button like you're going to take a
photo but no no no you're actually going
to take a video you just hit the video
button right here and placed it there on
purpose so that you would
push it
now next up is this button right here
it's the video button now we've done
things a little bit differently and no
one has ever actually done this before
you push the button and when you release
the button it stops
recording
right
hold down this button right here see
look at me look at me look at me look at
me look at me i'm recording
so if you see there i'll release the
button so i've stopped recording so now
i'm going to push it again and this will
allow me to continue to record look at
me look at me i'm recording i'm
recording
it is quite an innovation because no one
has ever done this before the push to
record the release to stop record will
take me to my filters which again this
is so innovative and new and fresh and
it feels great so here we go
definitely innovative i'm not sure if
that's the word choice that i would use
but anyway thank you so much for being
here june i really appreciate you
showing us the demo and sharing all of
your time with us so i look forward to
seeing what you guys come up with next
oh we've got so many plans here at
instagram especially evolving the
platform to be
more like the facebook that you've grown
and loved we want you to be able to like
comments we want to change that little
heart that you guys are so familiar with
we want to make it a little thumbs up
you may have seen that on facebook so we
would like to bring that over
to
our instagram
[Music]
thank you and thank you guys for
watching make sure you follow me on both
instagram and vine and i look forward to
hearing the debate from you guys which
one you prefer why why not i will see
you guys my next video if you guys have
any questions for june please do leave
them below and maybe i'll bring her back
to answer some of them
[Music]